i uh i i got waitlisted
everywhere berkeley
and harvard i want to start with the
ending of this movie because
you guys left things off with quite the
cliffhanger uh elle gets into harvard
and berkeley
she lies and says that she was wait
listed i would love to hear
your take on the ending and why l
did what she did because she's dishonest
come on
no um you know um she i feel like she's
had a lot of pressure in the last movie
from the men in her life right so
unfortunately i
feel like she you know they have a
really wonderful relationship i guess in
the story but
the fact that she's scared to uh tell
either of them because it's a difficult
decision is a little bit
you know so she probably feels like a
lot of pressure from both parties which
is unfortunate
she's really good at getting herself
into a pickle that is for sure
uh elle evans is notorious for trying to
make
everybody happy which in turn the way
she goes about it makes
everybody mad in the long run including
herself um
but wouldn't be a movie without it you
know so um ella has a lot of figuring
out to do
and you know she figures out a lot
during this movie and then in the end
she gives herself more figuring out to
do which is crazy because we don't know
what's gonna happen like i don't
know if we're ever gonna see her again
so you know you
you can hope that we do but i don't know
if we will and you know i just
i don't know why she does that do you
think you
know we're meant to be together i always
thought we were
i mean the ending does set things up for
a potential
third movie is that something that each
of you guys would be
interested in doing should the
opportunity
present itself i would love to
i mean as i i might be a little bit
biased but i actually
think that the our second movie is
better than our first
i just i love it i think it's so good
um and as much as the fans gave us so
much support on the first movie and got
us the second one like
who knows might happen again um but
that's
up to netflix exactly like our fans
loved the first one
so much and they ultimately are how we
got
to do a second one so if they are loud
enough
about this one about hopefully making a
third one
maybe netflix will i don't know grant us
the permission
would you be up for doing a third film
i'm not sure hey you know so many of
these things end with cliffhangers and
kind of leave it up to interpretation
um myself personally i don't even you
know i don't know what
i don't know what i'm doing after this
phone call sorry
so if they called and they were like the
fans freaking love the sequel
we're making a third you you don't know
that you would say yes
i have no idea hey katie i have no i'm
not kidding
i have no idea you're gonna you're gonna
break so many fans hearts for that
answer
yeah well get ready for life you know
we see marco not quite ready to give up
on l
what did that signify for you
i mean for me i i felt like it was
the perfect ending to the beginning of a
third film
and i have no idea if netflix will be
doing one
but i'm i'm i was telling mazie earlier
that i have a hashtag justice
for marco trending i'm just i'm
hopefully
trending because we we need justice for
marco
if i find someone smart funny and like
the same stuff i like
and hold on to them there's also a
possible love triangle that
could blossom in a third movie because
marco doesn't quite seem to be
over l completely so what did you make
of that and how she handled that whole
storyline i think elle is a young gal
who makes mistakes just like all of us
do
and i think that she you know went
through this
up and down roller coaster with noah and
his life at harvard
and then this person comes in as like a
pillar of strength to her and helps her
out so much with
emotions and personal life that um
things get confusing i don't know i feel
like if you get told no you should take
the note you know
take the l man take the last move on
yeah seriously it's like i like you but
i love him
i feel well i would i don't know i feel
like
leave her alone you know that's not even
a partner in the movie that's just as a
as a as a human being you know kids
listen what are you doing here
where's noah you left you weren't
looking for you
wait what elsa maisie really loved chloe
do you guys i mean feel like there's
more story to tell with both marco
and chloe in a potential third movie
hugely i feel like they both finally get
you know
their feet off the ground and then it
ends so i think we want to do a third
film i don't know how we would do the
kissing booth close-knit
that's true chloe has so much more to
teach noah i mean
definitely i want to see her and l like
you know i want to see that relationship
develop i want to see how she interacts
with
you know marco that'd be so fun please
you're asking yourself if it's worth
changing all of your plans for him
i love this city i love this girl do you
think that
ellen noah our end game
yeah yeah why not i think so all right
oh
here we go yeah now we're making the
fans happy
i don't know i mean you know just like
elle says in the trailer she always
thought they were
but things change things happen and i
don't know exactly where their story
will take them